[SPEAKER_01]: Second Wealsun, as Jude and Paul rush back towards the docks as they see their ship under attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you've used your action to dash, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, totally.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it'll just be reaction for a shield.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he said he was going to dodge.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I saw you roll that one.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't roll around one.
[SPEAKER_01]: A creature that comes out of the water right there with a sphere.
[SPEAKER_01]: This creature looks like a man in shape only, but it has a huge mouth with sharp teeth.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a wide mouth fast.
[SPEAKER_01]: Its eyes are these black orbs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Doesn't matter, fuck em up.
[SPEAKER_02]: They look completely lifeless.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck em up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another one comes here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another one comes here, Jude, and you see him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, can you give me an idea of how many feet, like how many hexes to the ship?
[SPEAKER_01]: Back here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck, so that's gonna be at least two more dashes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, maybe three dashes.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the ship is, as we're running...
[SPEAKER_02]: The ship is fully...
[SPEAKER_02]: It's in combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's in combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hardcore combat.
[SPEAKER_01]: They look outnumbered.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And is it just right here that we see, or do we see sea shit popping up even more?
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess what I'm asking is that...
[SPEAKER_01]: Deeper down, you see people coming up onto the docks from the water, pulling themselves up to be in your way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so there's more than just your fish sucker face and sucker face.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like, as you would run along the docks, there's a whole bunch of shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dozens.
[SPEAKER_01]: Motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Finish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude gets a 24.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here's what they get.
[SPEAKER_01]: 13.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay Jude, you first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'm gonna need to know if I want to help the ship, like if I move forward 30 feet, so 5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, what's the distance to the ship if I wanted to even try to help it with a large, like with a fireball, 120 foot spell?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm trying to figure out...
[SPEAKER_02]: I would say the battle with the ship is 200 feet down the dock.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're going to have to go about 100 feet if you're going to be able to do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: So one, two, three, four, five, six, that's 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: 100 feet is to here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, well, if I go 30 feet...
[SPEAKER_02]: What I'm saying is can I cast a 120-foot spell and help anybody?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's 150 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'd have to go 50 feet at least beyond that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so I would have to dash this round, and how many people would I be leaving in my wake?
[SPEAKER_02]: So I know you've got here, here, so there's at least three.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are people crawling up onto the docks on either side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not worth it.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, you realize that
[SPEAKER_01]: Had you not been there to do the fireball and to do the wall of fire, the men would have been between the hobgoblins shooting down upon them and the sahaugin that are moving out of the water to ambush you.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is obviously an ambush.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the only reason your men were able to push up over the wall and do what they were doing was because you were able to blow the front line of the hobgoblins away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me look up lightning bolt.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just want to know if I can fork it, and if I can fork it how far.
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume I probably can't hit all three.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you can't do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I could probably hit two?
[SPEAKER_01]: If you move to here, you could probably, but it'd be hard to see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or 5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, and then shoot it that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would do that, but there are guys over here that would be able to reach you at that point.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like within their round?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they'd be able to move to attack you.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can also go right over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I got to yell to you and I got to say back.
[SPEAKER_02]: I gotta say back, back with the Sarge.
[SPEAKER_02]: So 5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, and I ready in action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Jude moves to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I back up.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I say back, back with the Sarge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it at least Jude?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I'm gonna ready in action in case somebody can't, in case I can't, I don't remember if they beat you, but I have my wand out and I'm just ready.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need to cover his ass.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if anybody gets near to Paul or attacks him, you're gonna attack?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, totally.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you back up to there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, because we can't help the ship now.
[SPEAKER_02]: The ship's on its own.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least the ship has like a hundred dudes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two dudes.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, not 200.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was only, oh, it was 250.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least the ship's got 200 fucking dudes.
[SPEAKER_00]: 200 Marines.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we need to keep our
[SPEAKER_02]: 20 guys alive, because that may be all that we have if the ship goes down.
[SPEAKER_02]: But at least the ship has 200, we can't help it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Jude backs up to there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I ready an action with my wand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Paul, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: So you see me skip to a halt, and you go... Yeah, we're all...
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: To where Jude is?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Paul moves back to where you are, and he's like, what are they?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to attack?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to ready an action?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I may as well attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you can basically say if these guys come at me, that's when I shoot my thing, and just wait for them to get into close range.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you come back, pull back your crossbow, and you're ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy charges forward with his spear coming.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to know, is this guy, this is one of those sea creatures that came out of the water?
[SPEAKER_01]: You have seen Sahaugin before in your life.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you know that this is a Sahaugin, a shark man that can breathe under the water and telepathically communicates with sharks, making them do its bidding.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any limitation for how long he can be above land?
[SPEAKER_02]: To my knowledge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Roll Arcanum.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I do have a mark, but I don't have a mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll nature.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your nature?
[SPEAKER_02]: Nature.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have intelligence.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's intelligence.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get a plus five, so roll it plus five.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've read some treaties that say that the sahaugin can be above the water for extended periods of time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not indefinitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: They must return to the waves, but it's ours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: But they're not going to be able to scour through the city.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whatever the shit that's probably happening on the ship is for sea creatures.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, so the island has areas that they could reach in time, but they're at a disadvantage far from the coast.
[SPEAKER_01]: Especially if you're able to fight from a bigger area.
[SPEAKER_01]: They don't like to go far from the coast very much.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, but the whole island is technically an island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So do you want to use your reaction now?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now what I'm going to do is just one blast because I get three.
[SPEAKER_02]: You said that's maximum effort.
[SPEAKER_02]: One blast, just three die damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, that's possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: So four-sided, it's an auto-hit, so it's a four-sided plus one.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's two, three, four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven points of damage on S1.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I blast him, just try to slow him down, put him all into his chest.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I will write down on my wand one shot.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good lord.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least I got like 200 dudes on the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but they said that they were outnumbered.
[SPEAKER_00]: He said that they were outnumbered.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, well, it's like a whole crap ton of sea creatures coming out.
[SPEAKER_00]: So one Marine's probably good for every five.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, but what that means is you've got like 30 dudes with gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: That ain't shady.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because gouge won't be like, motherfuckers, I'm taking charge.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we got 20 guys with us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nobody in our group's dropped yet, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just two guys have been hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, more than that, more like five guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three archers and two marines.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the wounds are minimal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, or at least maybe like one or two of them are halfway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul, do you want to use your saved action to fire, or do you care?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't waste that, dude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Shoot the one that he just shot.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll, and then kicks a 27 die.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sand in his face.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven plus six is thirteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ooh, what's it got?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's close.
[SPEAKER_01]: Couldn't be easy about this.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's only got, like, leather armor.
[SPEAKER_01]: That hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah!
[SPEAKER_02]: Boom!
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, roll a die.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eight plus four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do some max, baby.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's 10 points of damage, so you've done 17 points of damage to this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: He does not fall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact...
[SPEAKER_02]: This guy's like at least third level.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe I am.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like, it's not even phasing him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dude, what if he had like a wind spell?
[SPEAKER_02]: So what I would tell my group is I would say, like, let's not talk about how many hit points you're down.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would say you are lightly bloodied, well bloodied, or near death.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I would try to make my group describe to each other.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, this guy has wounds on him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he would be like, well bloodied.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's just coming.
[SPEAKER_02]: He'd be like, well bloodied, but he ain't near death.
Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: An ish.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, this isn't good.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, now we're going to be defending you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dad, I might die.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why would you die?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got... Oh, I forgot.
[SPEAKER_00]: You took a shot, didn't you?
[SPEAKER_00]: I've already taken a shot and I've only got a max of 22.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you well-bloody or are you near death?
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't tell me how to do this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean well-bloody and not bloody at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you're between lightly bloodied and well bloodied.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, well, as far as I'm concerned, you're still great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, that's great.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Six, plus four, ten.
[SPEAKER_00]: No way I'm dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: All I can tell you is the alert feat is looking better every time.
[SPEAKER_01]: So hog in.
[SPEAKER_01]: They get eleven, twelve.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that motherfucker's gonna catch up to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy runs at you and attacks you with his spear savagely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, real quick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sarge.
[SPEAKER_02]: What about him?
[SPEAKER_02]: The Sarge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Didn't the Sarge roll?
[SPEAKER_02]: What if one of these...
[SPEAKER_01]: They're out of the combat right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I thought maybe they'd be like...
[SPEAKER_01]: They could be, but you don't know what they're doing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: He attacks with advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Advantage?
[SPEAKER_00]: How?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that because you're running?
[SPEAKER_02]: He smells blood.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, it's sharp!
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a sharp worker!
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god, you're leaking blood!
[SPEAKER_02]: You're leaking blood!
[SPEAKER_00]: Dude, I'm totally dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, alright, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hang on, hang on.
[SPEAKER_01]: So here is its spear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: These are plus three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think you made it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then he swipes at you with his claw.
[SPEAKER_01]: We got it, we got it, we got it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like fifth level.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss!
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes!
[SPEAKER_01]: Get out of his way!
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, how do sharks have claws?
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, is there more than one shark coming up?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, there's three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, fucker.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which one did we hit?
[SPEAKER_02]: The S1.
[SPEAKER_02]: S1.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so we both hit S1.
[SPEAKER_02]: This one attacks you, Jude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Luckily, you're not bleeding, so he doesn't get an advantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's his spear.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've also got 30.
[SPEAKER_01]: One.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, does it break?
[SPEAKER_02]: Critical fail.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, the spear breaks.
[SPEAKER_01]: He pokes into the ground next to you and breaks.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then he bites at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, he gets that bite attack?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: He gets two attacks and bites at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, two.
[SPEAKER_02]: One.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, there's two.
[SPEAKER_02]: It breaks the teeth off.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: All his teeth run out of his mouth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Attacks Paul with his spear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul takes five, six points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sticks the spear in you.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was a barbed.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you have 13 off you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine left.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Claw.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who, who, who, man?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I'm still on you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got like two hit points probably left.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why don't I have nothing to hit?
[SPEAKER_01]: Five, six points of damage on you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen off you.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this guy is like...
[SPEAKER_01]: Sticks you with a spear and slashes you across the chest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Luckily, you have your mask on, so it doesn't do anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna fireball him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude, I've got three hit points left.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I'm gonna fireball him, motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna fireball him and yell for Sarge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sarge, this ain't healthy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, these other guys run up to here at the gas.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, when you say these, these other guys, you just- They were the ones on the docks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So now it's a niche?
[SPEAKER_01]: Five right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you guys haven't gone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, that's right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna fireball and I can metamagic.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hang on a second.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wizards don't metamagic.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wizards do not have metamagic.
[SPEAKER_02]: Skull.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's Skull.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have Skull Spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, so what I meant was I can protect him from the fireball.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're first, Jude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I'm gonna protect his ass from the fireball.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so this is the way it works.
[SPEAKER_01]: Skull Spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: In your sculpting of spells, you can select an area, and one plus the level of the spell, so up to four people, can be sculpted around.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have to make a saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they make the saving throw in an area effect, they get advantage on their saving throw.
[SPEAKER_01]: Read what Sculpt Spells does.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you choose the number of them equal to one plus spells level, the chosen creatures automatically succeed on their saving throws against a spell, and they take no damage if they would have normally taken half damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That makes sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so basically you guys are fine, but you have to do it with two people if you want to drop it right on top of each other.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm dropping it right on top, because I want to get each one of these motherfuckers with a fireball.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically you drop it there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you want you and Paul to be sculped.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so I'm all... Alright, the damage is going to be 8 die 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: 8 die 6, wow.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, give me your eight-sideds.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six-sideds.
Six-sideds.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we have six-sideds, six available.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then we can roll two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there's seven dice, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it only eight?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's six die right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you can roll two more after you're done.
[SPEAKER_01]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll be here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, now one more after you're done.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ooh, that's nasty.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ooh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five, ten, plus 12 is 22.
[SPEAKER_01]: 22 plus 4 is 26, and one more.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll do yours.
[SPEAKER_01]: 26 plus 5 is 31 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: So Jude opens up this explosion on these five creatures from the waters.
[SPEAKER_01]: They do not like fire.
[SPEAKER_02]: No!
[SPEAKER_02]: That's right, they have disadvantage!
[SPEAKER_01]: No, they do not have fire vulnerability, but it seems like something that could happen to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You deal with it as you will.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's got three hit points.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't face Prince Jamis without him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so, DC, they have a DC 16, they get no dexterity bonuses here.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's five of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: One makes it, two make it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to randomly decide which ones.
[SPEAKER_01]: And this is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they are 1 and 3.
[SPEAKER_01]: These two make it.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy dies.
[SPEAKER_01]: Those just are engulfed in the flames and burn.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy takes 16 and this guy takes 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: He should be dead, the guy in front of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, maybe not, but not if they... No, this guy has.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, the guy that was half already died.
[SPEAKER_02]: We would have gotten too lucky if it was just one guy left.
[SPEAKER_01]: And 16 off him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so what I want to do is I want to stand, because I can still move.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I make myself a target over Paul?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you cannot make yourself a target over Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: What you can do is you can back up and say, Paul, get back here, and he can use a bonus action to disengage and move back up and either dash or fire down at one of these guys with his bow.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I should probably move 30 feet?
[SPEAKER_01]: If you want to, you can get back up to the top of the stairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, 5, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll move to there, yell for the Sarge.
[SPEAKER_02]: And...
[SPEAKER_02]: Charge!
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Jude blows them away and then moves back up.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you going to do, Paul?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm disengaging and I'm... You use your bonus action to disengage, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you go, get behind me.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could dash.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just going to dash right into the end though.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, the Sarge had spread people out, so when I called the Sarge- You see the Sarge's unit maybe 100 feet that way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, do you want to attack that sahaugin, or do you want to dodge?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to get off the line.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to move over.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to dash.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cheers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, one, two, three, four, five, six.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to get off the line.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to go towards the line?
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me go right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you basically go this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to get off the line.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll hold the ground, because I haven't taken any damage yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so Paul backs up behind you, maybe 40 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's super fucked up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, he's near death.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's stumbling.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's been badly wounded.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get the fuck out of here!
[SPEAKER_02]: That's not flea, by the way.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: One.
[SPEAKER_01]: They get ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten, you win.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I?
[SPEAKER_02]: You can shoot and slow back up, because you did your back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you can also back up and then get ready with an action.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if anybody comes up to attack Jude, you can shoot them with a crossbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm ready.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you back up, do you want to back up 30 feet?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I'm just... Well, yeah, you probably still do because you're well within range.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're well within range.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want to stay out of their charging range?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, then I'll move back a bit farther to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you move back 30 more feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're about, I would say, 80 feet from Jude, and you're ready in action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I yell for the Sarge?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sarge!
[SPEAKER_02]: We can't!
[SPEAKER_02]: Goddamn, we're getting our asses kicked.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're screwed, man.
[SPEAKER_02]: End of story.
[SPEAKER_02]: Game over, man.
[SPEAKER_02]: Game over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, let's see.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I did just fireball their fish skin ass.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six, and then dash.
[SPEAKER_01]: This one dashes to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: He will not be able to attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, because he dashed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you wish to attack that guy?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you shoot out with your crossbow.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you get to roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get to roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not an advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, you can sneak attack the guy because he's been five feet of enemy.
[SPEAKER_01]: So hit him, hit him, and then you can do extra damage as a sneak attack.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you can do a one die eight plus two die six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's 12 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy comes up over the rise to leap on Jude and you hit him in the throat.
[SPEAKER_01]: He falls there.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, this guy can only go to here.
[SPEAKER_01]: But he does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because he had still taken half damage from my fireball.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm a fireball on myself!
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just one guy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I know that, do I know that he's been burned at least?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, we know he's damaged.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where is, so that's the shark guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that the guy that died or is that the guy that just came out?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, that guy that died is right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's dead, he's basically writhing on the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, if I pull back, am I gonna draw in an attack or do I need to just stay there?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's an opportunity to attack unless you want to use your action.
[SPEAKER_01]: To disengage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, nope.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna put three rounds into him because I know he's got burned at least, even if he's half.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you use your wand and just fire at him.
[SPEAKER_01]: So roll four die four?
[SPEAKER_01]: Three die four?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, three die four plus three, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that is 25 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: He falls.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to back up 30 feet?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, after the fact.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are more Sharkmen down the beach.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, definitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to back up 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you back up 30 feet to where Paul is.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm also yelling for the Sarge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, basically...
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys get off the beach.
[SPEAKER_01]: And start running back to where the unit is.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if the unit is kind of over here or in the center...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: What we need to do is coalesce.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as we're backing up, we need to push into the Citadel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, hang on a second.